comment se comporter lorsqu'on assiste
un spectacle car sacha guitry il a dit
avant nous de même qu'il ya de bons et
de mauvais acteurs les spectateurs ont
plus ou moins de talent intéressé que
nous sommes à l'amélioration de l'espèce
nous avons eu l'idée de composer à
l'intention d'autres publics
une sorte de code du spectateur fruit
d'une déjà longue observation d'abord
l'entrée dans la salle
vous êtes en retard le spectacle est
commencée depuis 20 bonnes minutes
même si vous êtes une personnalité un
notable faites vos tout-petits écrasé
vous commencez à un huissier de des
vergers vos voisins et fatalement les
actes ça va ça va mieux que bien sûr on
a loupé le début
le spectacle est quelquefois dans la
salle mais celui qui est sur scène
risque parfois d'en souffrir si
décidément vous arrivez en retard ce qui
est très mal mais parfois excusable eu
égard aux difficultés de la circulation
et du karting à leurs buts et à battre
que ce soit myopie ou simplement
distraction faites tout de même
attention vos posé les pieds et le reste
dans le cas d'hervé yeux d'un spectacle
comique qui tiendrait ses promesses
laissez vous aller bien sûr riez pouffer
esclaffé vous tordez de banque un mais
on est vite on possible de le faire à
contretemps à l'élection du koala trop
peut être que ces excès d'enthousiasmé
risque parfois de gêner l'entourent à
fresco si gênante lassitude contraire
qui consiste à traumatiser littéralement
tout spectateur qui savourait comme il
convient loubet ouvrage représente et
humour dont la subtilité
elle semble heureuse si vous vous
échapper elle reli kyo même je suis
désolé je suis l'auteur
dans la liste des casseurs d'ambiance le
plus redouté d'écouté de la rampe
enfants en bas âge amateurs de bonbons
dans leur paquet chien dépressif et
cetera le photographe amateur ou
professionnel mérite une place de choix
tant il est vrai que la désinvolture de
son comportement et son évidente à
différence aux péripéties de la
représentation qui se déroule devant lui
fried quelquefois le tapotage il ya
aussi la dame bilingue qui offre à son
compagnon étrangers et à quelques autres
une version doublée presque simultanées
cause a dit chez nietzsche et qu'elle à
gaza par l'internet on les connaît walt
sa gamme années comme suzuka adresse t
vergogne achètent ou pas il y a le
joyeux drille le farceur de service qui
recherchent le dialogue entre la salle
et la scène et les valeurs et règles
et puis il y a les silencieux qui ne
réagissent pas qui ne branche pas qui ne
rient pas ne sourit pas ils sont
généralement placés au premier rond nous
regarde fixement avec une sorte de
rancune proche de la haine qui est
extrêmement traumatisant possibilité de
même dans une seule de 3000 personnes
chauffée à blanc nous ne voyons plus que
nous sommes fascinés par ondes il a ce
demander mais qu'est ce qu'on leur a
fait à ces deux là ne bouge pas ne
bougeront pas refusons de participer à
l'euphorie générale dans un ultime
affrontement
que